JIAHAO LI: My name is Jiahao Li.
And my SuperUROP project is
about making your program run
faster.
So nowadays, computer systems,
especially computation
dense ones, have more
than one CPU cores.
So people need to write
parallel program in order
to utilize all those
cores simultaneously.
However, the compiler
we have today
is not very effective
at optimizing
these parallel programs.
So my project aims
to change that.
And our primary
approach actually
stems from this
observation that there
are a lot of optimizations that
our compiler does today that
work perfectly on
serial programs
but fail to translate
to parallel programs,
because of the unfamiliar
parallel constructs that can
be found in parallel programs.
So in order to address
this, we actually
drew our inspiration from a
prior project called Tapir.
So when we have a
parallel program,
we create a mirror
program of it that does
the exact same computation.
But we get rid of all
the parallel constructs.
We call it the serial projection
of this parallel program.
We then run the
compiler optimization
on the serial projection.
And for each transformation
the optimization does,
we mirror it back onto the
parallel program, the one
we want to optimize.
So by doing this in the
evaluation that we have run,
we have been able to observe
of a speed-up of up to 31%
on certain benchmarks.
So this means the program would
take 31% less time to run.
So I think with this we have
demonstrated that is, indeed,
possible and feasible
to effectively implement
the optimization for parallel
programs in a compiler.